All right. So let's look at the product performance
worksheet. And if you
remember from the last video we talked about the the process
of breakthrough advertising and in the first step
of that process is taking the time
to understand the mass desire that's in the market.
If you remember that that visual of the river just flowing representing
desire.
So we've taken the time to understand what it
is that our Market wants.
We've also taken the time to understand the motivation behind
their desire. The reason that
they want to achieve this transformation whatever
it is. And so that's the first step the
Second Step then is is then understanding.
How our products or service addresses that
desire and in very specific terms.
And to do that we start to look at features and benefits. And
so I want to show you just
how we've set up this worksheet here
and then show you some examples. So you just start with listing out
the product name here list just
one feature what it is list why that features included
and then talk about one of the benefits of
of the the
product here. This is Gene calls
this your product in action. So when somebody is using your product, what
does it look like? So you're just doing these one
at a time in this map back to
the specific features. You'll see in a second and one
one thing that's helpful is when you're thinking about the benefit or
the product in action is if you need
help getting Clarity on the importance
of that benefit you can you can start your
sentence with so you can you know, so this benefit is
here so you can do XYZ and
then we're going to look at the benefit of the benefit.
So we're this is the theme that you'll see is like we
just want to keep going deeper because we want to understand our Market
better than anybody else. Like that's how you that's how
you create breakthroughs is you do the work that nobody else is
willing to do and then what we do is after we've
we've kind of gone down
this this trail of understanding features and
benefits for our product and the benefit of the benefit we
start starting to think of like
is you look at this. What's the dominant emotion that that comes
out of licking at
what you've just written and then is there
a desire from our desire worksheet
that this would map back to and this
may be easier just to understand with with an
example. So let me hop in there so
This is the example that that Kim used in
in our sessions. I'll start with that. But if you've
got an air purifier, you know, one of the features may be
that it has a HEPA filter that removes
tiny particles, right? So that's
just one one of the features. So why is this
feature included in here you
can kind of get creative with.
You write a little bit of like what your copy might look like
for example, so you just answering this question. So these dangers tiny
particles include deadly viruses like covid
10 yet. They're too small to be trapped by ordinary HEPA
filter. So that's why this feature is included and what's
the benefit of this feature? So,
So you can feel safer knowing you're
protected from invisible germs and viruses. That's that's
what it looks like in action. And then
what's the benefit of this benefit here?
So you can stop worrying about
breathing and nasty germs which lowers anxiety. So
the benefit is feel safer
knowing you're protected. The reason that's important is because
this benefit allows you to stop worrying
about breathing in nasty germs and if
you want to keep going, you know, so you can do the benefit of the
benefit of the benefit there. There's no
there's nothing stopping you here.
But we just give you two and then the dominant
emotion that this, you know, if you imagine you put
yourself in the shoes of your prospect the dominant emotion here, you
know, if you're somebody who's worrying about breathing
and nasty germs you've got this this
feeling of fear and what
that what it feels like to have that fear resolved.
Of knowing that you're no longer going to be breathing in those those germs
and then there's this emotion of feeling safe
that if I buy this product there's going
to be safety attached to that and then there's also freedom
I think in the sense of I don't have to
worry about these things anymore and you
know a potential matching desire in
the market would be human connection. So I
want to spend I want to develop my
friendships deeper friendships and
part of that is I want to have them over in my house.
But I have a tremendous fear
of the germs that they'll bring in from
the outside world for it. For example.
If we take one so you all have purchased
the Richter advertising Mastery Book. And so I you
know, we eat our own dog food. So I use this this is actually what
I use. So if you look at some of this language here, you'll see it in the
cells letter that I wrote for Rick to advertising. So
you've got here. Let's
take one of these worksheets reads.
Yeah. We'll do this one. So break the advertising
Mastery is the product. One of
the features is there are worksheets for the exercises, which
is what you're looking at right now. It's very
meta. So why is this feature included you
will want to practice more than once on more than
one offer. You need to be able to duplicate templates quickly
so you can reach your breakthrough faster.
So that's why it's included and then
what's the benefit of this feature so worksheets for the exercises? So
you don't have to waste time
creating your advertising toolkit from scratch use our
worksheets as your template and just follow the
instructions instructions. You can innovate as you master
the concepts. All right, so what's the benefit of this?
You get to find your breakthrough faster than others
because you aren't trying to reinvent everything from scratch.
The book was written in 1966. So
why reinvent so here what we're
what we're talking about is is this
idea of speed so I'm honing
in on people and in our
marketing copywriting space that one of
the things they they desire is being able
to move quickly and with purpose and
and make a few mistakes along the
way as possible as they're developing their copyrighting skills.
So the dominant emotion here, there's a
feeling of hope there's an a
feeling of excitement that I'm going to be able to implement
break throughout housing faster than other people and so
matching desire here again, I
come back to speed and you can see that the speed is something that that
we focused in on a
lot and developing.
you know the reason this matters so
speed to to implementation speed to
understanding the concepts quickly so that
you can
Apply them because you have to understand them before you apply them and and
there's some more examples here. I'm not going to go through
through these but you can sort of see how we use this and this
is just really to get your
your brain thinking and one of these. Oh, yeah, here's here's a
good example. So I want to call this out. So as I was going through this exercise
I came up with this phrase, you know marketing muscle
memory and and that was
just sort of like a little accident that happened and I really like that
phrase and end up using it in the cells letter and there are
a couple more items like that. But this this
is one that really stuck out to me because that
that phrase came directly out of doing
this exercise. So this is
this is step two in the process of
It is a step two in the process
of identifying the the mass
desire in the market and then matching.
How are our specific product addresses that
desire and satisfies it by looking
at each individual feature and benefit
and then matching it to the desire that is satisfies. So this
is part two and then the next step was once
we know how we address the the desire and the
market we then.
Go further and understand. What is the market know about
its problem? What does it know about its desire? This gets
us into levels of awareness. So I just want to kind of paint that picture for
you. So you understand, you know, how these
worksheets fit together and obviously you
have any questions reach out anytime but this is the product performance worksheet.